David Tabachnikov,
good to see you.
How are you?
I’m awesome. How are you?
Fantastic!
Thank you for being on the show.
You’re actually calling
from Serbia, right?
Yes. Thank you
for having me and
I'm in Belgrade.
Why Serbia?
Why Serbia? I actually,
to be fair,
Serbia is basically
has been my base after
I left Tel-Aviv in 2016.
And I’ve been a digital nomad
for quite a while.
A digital nomad?
What does that mean, digital nomad?
A digital nomad is
somebody who is basically
location independent,
somebody who doesn’t tie
his work or his activities
to a specific location
while doing his,
most cases,
doing his job digitally.
So, it can be the web developers,
marketing, teachers,
architects, anything -
- So anything
... laptop.
Anything that doesn’t require to
to use your hands
to assemble something.
Okay, I like that.
Yeah.
And you’re the CEO
of ScholarshipOwl,
and you’ve been doing
some pretty incredible work
to help a lot a lot of people
around the world
find scholarships
and get proper education.
So, tell me a little bit
about that and what is this
world of education?
Right.
I think you need
to move a little bit,
oh there you go
you’re back in focus.
Okay. Is this good?
Perfect.
... It’s becoming
a bit dark
because it’s 8 PM
for me, so
No ... this out, yeah.
So, tell me
what is ScholarshipOwl
and what is this thing about,
Why do we need
to even deal with this subject?
All right.
So, I’ll start with the
basically, the problem.
And the problem is that
in the US, specifically,
the education is
extremely expensive
And substantially more so
than in any other country.
In fact, in the past eight years,
the cost of tuition
has been going eight times
faster than the wages.
Wow!
- Okay.
- Yes.
Well how much are we
talking about tangibly here?
An average family pays per student
$26,000.
- Per year?
- That’s an average
per year, right.
I know cases of $70,000
and $90,000 as well.
Right.
So, numbers are huge.
To put it into a perspective,
a master’s degree in the UK
is kept by 9,000 pounds.
And that’s some of the most
expensive education in Europe.
Interesting. Okay.
So, why is that
though an issue?
So, yeah, we can say
you want to go
to a better university,
you’re gonna have
to pay more.
Are there not options
that are financially viable
for everybody?
Is that the issue?
So, there are all kinds
of government programs,
and there’s a subject
of student loans as well,
which has been talked a lot.
- Right, yeah.
- And student loans
is basically an attempt of the
government and private companies
to help students pay
those high tuition costs.
I believe, actually,
the student debt
is the second largest debt
in the US,
if not the most.
- It is. It is
No it's the second one.
It’s $1.7 trillion
and going by almost -
Trillion dollars.
Trillion dollars, yeah.
That's a big market to go after, David.
It’s more than many
countries in the world.
And it’s been going
by around $100 billion a year
for the past five years.
- Crazy.
- It's crazy numbers.
It’s crazy numbers.
But the thing is that
the student loan industry,
in a way, it’s
it’s the one that drives
the tuition fee cost up
because the more loans
are available, the more money
the universities are taking
because they know
that the students can afford
to take more money in loans.
Interesting.
Okay, wait. So what you’re describing
here is this vicious cycle where
there’s more loan programs,
whether it’s by banks
or by government,
the universities see that,
and say, “Okay.
Well, actually now,
every kid on the block
can just go get a loan
from the bank.
Pay it over 30, 40 years.
So, why don’t we just raise
the tuition because
they can just get a bigger loan.
And now, we’re gonna" -
Yeah, but it’s just vicious, obviously.
Yeah, but you said it right,
every kid on the block.
So, basically, you’re telling
a 17-year-old kid,
“Now, take $100,000 in loan
that you will need to pay
with huge interest.”
We’re talking
like 8% to 14% interest.
It's huge interest.
Like, you have no,
no current history,
no other measurement of
how will you be able to repay it.
- That's right.
That's right.
So, how do you calculate
the interest?
And that’s how you end up with very,
very high interest
on that.
- Wow.
And you ask that
from a 17-year-old kid
like to make the decisions.
Of course, he’s going to be
talking to his parents,
and so on.
But at the end of the day,
it’s very easy to be overwhelmed.
- But ... because
that kid needs an education
and if this is the only way
to get an education,
then it doesn’t matter
what the interest rate is.
Even if it’s 20%,
you have to do it,
otherwise you won’t even have
a chance here.
And let’s be honest,
most families do not have
$26,000
lying around to,
per year.
Most families don’t have $400
to pay in an emergency fund
if the car breaks down.
I heard that
in one of my economics classes.
I was shocked beyond belief.
Exactly. Exactly.
$400, most families don’t have
as emergency money.
I think
I just want to,
you said, like you know
We grew up in a considerably
more privileged world
than 4 billion people here
where we can go out
to restaurants.
We can eat.
We can go to university.
We can study and we’re engineers.
And I think, sometimes,
also for me, it’s hard to
it’s easy to forget
that a lot of others
don’t have these opportunities
and that’s why
I’m also so excited
about what you’re doing
with ScholarshipOwl
to level the playing field
and allow everybody there.
Exactly.
Now, student loans is one,
like you said,
it’s a vicious cycle.
A vicious cycle.
But part of the money, obviously,
comes from savings
that the parents have saved
beginning
the savings programs
from when the kid is born.
Part of that comes from
different types of scholarships.
And scholarships does
a few different types.
Some of them are
institutional scholarships
given by the college,
by the state,
by the government, and so on.
And some of them are private,
given either by private companies
or philanthropy funds,
by different organizations,
which are not related
to the education system itself
directly, okay?
- Right.
Basically, any company
can give out
or any brand
can give out a scholarship.
And they do it, in many cases,
either because it’s considered
a donation, so they get
tax breaks on that.
Okay.
Other because they want
to get the message across
in different ways.
You have a scholarship for
to not to drink and drive,
for example.
So, they want students
to get the message,
they offer a scholarship.
And unlike many -
Wait. What does that mean,
scholarship with the conception of
don’t drink and drive?
Basically, in order to apply
to many of the scholarships,
you need to do something
to actually apply.
In many cases,
it can be either an essay,
or an image
or video that you need to record.
Hmm?
The students apply.
The students write the essay
or fill out the application, right?
Exactly, yes.
But the organization
that offered the scholarships
decides what the
requirements are gonna be.
Okay.
So, if you're an organization
that tries to fight accidents
caused by the drunk drivers,
you can make the scholarship,
like one of the scholarships
to write an essay
on why drinking
and driving is bad
Okay.
Which means the students
will need to research that,
learn about it,
write an essay about it,
and they get the message across.
That makes sense.
Unlike just putting a TV ad
or something saying,
“Don’t drink and drive,"
making a scholarship
for that causes the student
to get to you
to hear your message,
to actually, internalize
the message.
Sure. Sure.
So, that’s kind of
one side of that equation.
The other side is that
this scholarship
then goes a student,
in most cases,
those outside scholarships
are between $1,000 and $5,000.
Mm-hmm.
And you don’t need to repay them.
You don’t need
to anything, but -
- Right, it's a scholarship.
- But the amount of students that -
It's a scholarship.
Exactly.
But the amount of students
that are awarded the scholarships
are very limited.
- Of course.
- So, where, so where do you -
- But there's a lot of them.
- So, where do you come into this?
- But, and that's exactly -
- there's a lot of
scholarships,
- there's a lot of them.
- a lot of students,
and there’s a lot of
big mishmash balagan on
matching them.
Right. Exactly.
And that’s exactly
where we come in.
Did I catch the problem right?
You caught the problem precisely.
Okay.
The thing is that
finding all the scholarships
with all the requirements
and all the eligibility
rules they have,
just going through them,
it's a full-time job.
No student can do that, right?
Of course.
And on top of that,
if you go to the easy scholarships,
like the no essay ones
or the ones with very easy,
there’s tens of thousands
of students that apply to them.
So, huge amount of competition
and they maybe award five of them.
- Right.
- That’s kind of the problem.
What we have done is we built
like we mapped all those
kinds of scholarships
with all the requirements,
eligibility, and so on.
And when the students
comes to us,
we build the profile
of the student
and we match the students
with all the scholarships
that the student's eligible to.
Now, they still need to do
some of the work.
They still need write an essay.
They still need to do -
- Right, of course.
- You know, maybe
record a video, and so on.
But given the data we have,
we will show him
and recommend the student
the scholarship
that he has the highest
chance of winning.
So, you'll ask the student, "Hey,
give us a little bit of an
Who are you?
What are your interests?
What are your passions?
Tell us everything
you can tell us.
And then, we will
We know of the 10,000
possible scholarships.
And we know
what they’re looking for,
so we can give you the top 10
so that you don’t have to go
to the other 990" Right? Or the -
- Exactly.
- Okay.
But we go the extra mile here,
because other than
knowing the 10,000 -
tens of thousands
of scholarships,
we also have millions
of students on the platform.
So, we know how many
other students
are eligible for each scholarship.
- Okay.
- So
the narrower the rules,
the higher the chances
that you will win -
Right.
which means that
if you invest the same 20 minutes
into writing an essay
on a scholarship
that has 10,000 applicants
versus a scholarship
that have a hundred -
So, David, it’s like Waze, right?
You know that there is a lot
of traffic in one lane.
You go to the other
and that this works well
because you worked for Waze.
Exactly.
Now I see where you got
where you got the inspiration.
Definitely, it’s Waze
for scholarships in a way, yes.
We’re trying to show you
Actually, that’s our slogan, right?
It's “The fastest route
to scholarships.”
Okay, you see?
I can go -
It’s exactly that.
- All right.
- You're welcome.
- David
- We'd love that.
Future Minds.
Talk to me about that.
I want to touch,
just before we go to Future Minds.
ScholarshipOwl is our student site.
Yeah.
And last year, we launched
scholarship app,
which is our brand
and organization site,
which is basically a CRM and a CMS
that helps organizations
to offer scholarships easily.
Basically manage
the scholarship itself,
manage the applicants,
manage the award winners,
and so on.
Right.
And we offer the scholarship app
completely for free.
Okay?
With the intention
to make the private scholarship
space as transparent
and trustworthy as possible.
So, basically,
like any organization
or company can come over,
and within 15 minutes,
publish a scholarship
and offer it,
basically increasing the amount
of supply of scholarships
to the demand from students.
So, basically,
we connected the two sites.
Okay.
And our mission as a company
is to make private scholarships
a viable alternative
to student loans.
Yeah.
So, a student goes
to our platform,
and if for now doesn’t replace
the student loans completely,
at least, takes a substantial bite
out of student loans
and owes a lot less.
But David, what is
How is the market balanced?
So, how many students
So, every year, how many
How much money do students
need in scholarships?
And how much money
is available through the 10,000
possible scholarships?
Is it about the same amount?
'Cause in my mind,
I would imagine
there is a huge disparity.
So, some of the students
we work with have won
tens of thousands of dollars
just in private scholarships.
Some of the advisers
we worked with got
hundreds of thousands of dollars
in private scholarships.
The majority of students
get nothing, if at all.
And that disparity
is exactly because of that
because it’s so hard
to know what to apply to.
If you have a good system
and you know what you are doing,
you will win scholarships.
Okay.
But to get to that system -
- And obviously every amount helps
It doesn’t even have
to be even,
I don’t need the full ride.
But even just getting me there
substantially
reduces the stress,
the anxiety,
but also the confidence
that I need to go and get
my academic education.
We like to think
of it that way.
Thousand dollars in scholarship
was worth $1500 in student loans.
Makes sense.
And that’s, I guess,
mainly looking
at the interest, right?
It’s not just the interest.
It’s
Well first you
anyway need to invest to work, right?
If you apply to a scholarship,
you need to invest,
it becomes front-loaded.
You need to invest
to work at the beginning.
Right.
If you go the student loan route,
you need to pay it later,
with interest,
when you’re in a different place
in your life. Basically,
you start paying
your student loans,
well depends
on many conditions,
but basically,
half a year after you graduate
or if you drop out,
which, and the statistics
of dropping out
are pretty awful, right?
Okay.
And in fact, 41% of the students
that drop out are dropping out
because of financial reasons.
Wow. That’s insane.
No, but David but I do wanna add also,
in my mind I can see
the viability
of the psychological aspect of it.
You’re getting a scholarship as
for any amount,
whether it’s a thousand dollar
or ten thousand dollars,
that vote of confidence
that somebody’s giving you,
and saying, “I believe in you.
Go and get your education.”
I think that has some impact.
But I can’t believe
we only have about,
five minutes left
and we have to do Future Minds
and I want to talk about the fact
that you’re completely remote,
which in the age of COVID
and the new 2020,
it's so relevant.
But first, Future Minds.
Tell me what this is about.
So, you mentioned COVID.
This week, we launch
Future Minds Fund,
which is based on
the infrastructure
and the products we already have.
It’s a non-profit organization,
which is made to help students
that were impacted by COVID-19,
finish their education.
We believe that if the students
that will drop out
because of COVID
won't finish their education,
we won't have
professionals tomorrow
to build the world.
We won't have
the future researchers
to cure the next pandemic.
And we have to
save this generation
because the students of 2020
will hurt the most in 20 years.
Like it's, the impact
that this pandemic
had on the students
is bigger than on many
other areas of life.
Right.
And Future Minds Fund
is built in a way that to,
Our platforms
students can apply
to those scholarships.
We basically launched.
We began by launching
three scholarships ourselves,
which were targeted at students
that lost their income
while studying.
So, if you had a side job
or things like that, and you lost it,
and you cannot
finish your studies
because of that.
Students that had to
rearrange their whole living
situation because they need to
now study from home.
You know you used to study in the library
or in
in college group,
you cannot do that anymore.
You need a chair. You need a desk.
You need a desk.
You need a chair.
You need a laptop.
You need maybe some books.
There's a lot
of things you need,
which you didn’t count for.
And like you said,
$400 can be a lot of money.
And now suddenly
you need to set up
the whole environment.
So, we begin by setting up
our own scholarships for that.
But then,
I’m sorry, I got distracted.
So, you set up your own
scholarship for that?
Yes. So, we set up our own
three scholarships for that.
And we got over 6,000 applicants
over one weekend.
Wow.
Somebody opened
the door and I got distracted.
No worries.
So, again
So, you launched
your scholarship
Let’s go back.
Yeah. So, we launched
three scholarships by ourselves,
basically scholarships
that are targeted
at helping students
that lost their side income
during the studies
because many
the students are dependent
on side income.
And you had
6,000 applicants, right?
And we had over 6,000 applicants
over one weekend alone.
One weekend.
So, we saw
there is a huge demand.
- And these are students
that were impacted by COVID
and they need assistance
to complete their studies.
This is not just any -
Only COVID.
The scholarships we launched
are only COVID-19-related.
So, where is this headed?
Can other organizations
come and also provide scholarships?
After we saw the demand,
which was way bigger
than we anticipated,
we reached out to a few
other organizations in
the higher education space
to help us out.
In that way, we’ve been able
to award 19 scholarships
also.
- Wow!
But when we saw the potential
of that, we decided to open it
to the general public.
Yeah.
And we launched
a non-profit organization
and a fund dedicated to that,
on which anybody, basically,
can go to our website,
see the story of each student
separately,
like how he was impacted.
What happened?
And then, it's like a GoFundMe
where they can sponsor students?
Exactly.
I love it.
Exactly. It’s a GoFund
It’s a public funding
campaign for students.
I love it.
David, very inspiring.
Is this
Do you see this specific
for COVID? And that said,
do you see this in the long-term
as a way for students
to share their story
and get assistance for education?
Where do you see this going?
I mean, our immediate goal
was to help the students
that were impacted now.
But I don’t see
why that wouldn’t become
a more permanent thing.
Right.
Helping different causes
and different
helping students impacted
by different situations
or conditions that are happening
- I love it.
- in the US
Yeah. David, very quickly, how
long have you been with ScholarshipOwl?
Or has the company
been living as a whole?
I’ve been with
ScholarshipOwl since 2015.
So, five years now.
- And how many
how many people are in it?
We’re now 35 people.
35 people and
everybody’s remote, right?
All remote.  As I like to say,
we're spread from Vegas to Bali.
I love it. Okay.
So, David, we’re gonna
have to do another episode,
which will be featured
a few months from now
where we only talk about
this remote thing because
I think that is just as relevant
to this whole new 2020.
And I need to learn how to start
working full time remote,
because, I think, we all have
to learn that now.
I think that COVID
has basically accelerated
the remote workspace
tens of years within one year.
Unbelievable.
David, right before we leave,
I need three words
that you would best
describe yourself.
And I’m gonna ask
you the same question
in a few months
when we do the next episode.
So, make sure
to be consistent.
[laughs] We’re ... recording
to remember, right?
Three words that describe myself.
Ginger
[laughs]
Committed and curious.
I love it.
Gingie, committed, and curious.
Right.
Beautiful.
David, thank you very much.
Toda raba.
And best of luck
with ScholarshipOwl.
I really hope
you get to help these thousands
of students now during COVID,
and thank you for the work
that you’re doing
for the millions of others
that need assistance
on a yearly basis
going into college.
I think you’re doing a great,
great service to all of them.
So, thank you.
Thank you very much for having me.
- Take care and bye-bye.
- And see you in a few months.
Bye.